[Música]
pasamos ahora a hablar de economía aquí
en directo América me acompaña en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches bienvenido vamos a comenzar
hablando de esas minutas que presentaron
en la última reunión de la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos Qué detalle se
conocieron de estos informes Santiago y
es que según la minuta la mayoría de los
funcionarios de la reserva Federal de
ese país mostraron A favor o partidarios
de reducir pronto la subida de los tipos
de interés una mayoría sustancial de los
funcionarios de la Fed cree que pronto
llegaría el momento de ralentizar este
actual ritmo de su vida de los tipos de
parte del Banco Central los funcionarios
señalaron que la persistencia de la
inflación sugiere que los tipos se
establecerán probablemente en niveles
algo más alto de lo que se esperaba
anteriormente las actas también
mostraron un debate emergente dentro de
los funcionarios de la fe sobre los
riesgos que el rápido de endurecimiento
de la política monetaria podría suponer
para el crecimiento económico y sobre
todo la estabilidad fina incluso cuando
los responsables de la política
reconocen que ha habido poco Progreso
respecto a bajar la inflación y que los
tipos todavía tienen que subir aún más
el dólar estadounidense cayó en general
después de conocerse el contenido de las
actas y este año Pues por mencionarlo el
dólar subió frente a todas las Divisas
importantes en máximos de dos décadas
motivados precisamente por este aumento
de los tipos de interés Jorge hablemos
ahora de la solicitudes de ayuda de
desempleo que aumentaron hasta el nivel
más alto que se había presentado en el
pasado mes de agosto pero siguen siendo
Bajos en comparación con los estándares
históricos Supongo estamos hablando de
Estados Unidos Estados Unidos también el
departamento del trabajo informó que 240
mil personas solicitar una ayuda para el
desempleo la semana pasada lo que supone
Un aumento de 17.000 personas respecto a
la semana anterior Los solicitudes de
prestación por desempleo son un
indicador de los despidos y los bajos
niveles actuales que demuestran que los
trabajadores estadounidenses todavía
gozan de una extraordinaria seguridad
laboral Pero puede que no sea por mucho
tiempo con el aumento de los tipos de
interés que mencionábamos anteriormente
el mercado de la vivienda cayó y muchos
economistas ya prevén que Estados Unidos
entren recesión el año que viene ya que
este aumento de Los costos de los
préstamos frena la actividad económica
los empleadores añadieron
261.000 puestos de trabajo el mes pasado
y están creando una media de casi
400.000 empleos al mes este año 2022 es
el segundo mejor año para la
contratación en los registros del
gobierno que se remontan a 1940 el
primer año o el año más fuerte de la
contratación fue 2021 pasamos a hablar
ahora del clima para los negocios en
nuestra región en América Latina que
subió en el cuarto trimestre del 2022
pero aún continúa siendo muy bajo como
es esto bueno el índice del clima que es
un indicador de América Latina que Se
elaboró con encuesta a 138 especialistas
de 15 países subió desde el 54 4,7
puntos en el tercer trimestre hasta 66,5
puntos en el último trimestre pese a esa
mejoría se trata del Tercer menor nivel
medido en los últimos seis años la
organización alertó que estos datos se
indican que el escenario para los
próximos seis meses tiende a
desacelerarse en la región en la
recuperación de la situación regional
también contribuyó el optimismo de los
economistas con respecto a la situación
de Brasil cuyo índice de clima
económicos del top desde el 54,5 puntos
hasta 84,5 puntos el mayor nivel en poco
más de un año otros países como Bolivia
México Paraguay y Perú registraron
aumentos de su índice de clima económico
y en la zona más crítica permanece en
chile y Argentina cuyos indicadores
empeoraron Mientras que el de Venezuela
por ejemplo dejó ya de ser evaluado
hablemos ahora de una situación que se
está presentando en Perú porque el
acceso ferroviario a Machu Picchu que es
un punto turístico muy importante para
ese país así como la ruta Busco puno
donde se encuentra el lago titicaca fue
suspendido por 48 horas porque los
trabajadores convocaron a huelga que
están reclamando bueno las empresas
ferroviarias inca y Perú las únicas
encargadas del acceso al Machu Picchu
confirmaron la suspensión por 48 horas
de los tramos cusco puno Arequipa por la
convocatoria de huelga de las
organizaciones sociales de la zona entre
las que se incluye el sector Agrario que
reclama por el aumento del precio de la
fertilizantes las organizaciones piden
al gobierno de Pedro Castillo que
solucionen problemas como el aumento del
costo de la vida El escaso presupuesto
destinado a salud y educación en el
cusco o el proyecto de masificación de
gas en camisea el anuncio del paro
ferroviario en las principales rutas
turísticas del país coincide con la
huelga de transportes convocada por la
unión Nacional de transportistas de
camiones de carga vamos a volver a
hablar de Estados Unidos porque este
país rechazará azúcar procedente de la
República Dominicana por denuncias de
trabajos forzados Estados Unidos dejará
prácticamente de el azúcar y productos
derivados hechos en República Dominicana
por la empresa Central Romana
Corporation Y es que según una
investigación de la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza de Estados Unidos
la compañía supuestamente aisló
trabajadores los retuvo les retuvo la
paga fomentó condiciones abusivas y
presionó Por horas extras excesivas el
año pasado la agencia ap visitó varios
puntos azucareros propiedad de Central
Romana donde varios obreros se quejaron
de mala paga de que los obligan a vivir
asignados y sin agua potable y de normas
restrictivas los obreros azucareros
también han organizado varias protestas
este año para exigir residencias
permanentes la mayoría inclusive de
ellos son haitianos tras vivir durante
muchas décadas trabajando en República
Dominicana Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización de las principales
noticias relacionadas con economía a
continuación en directo América ya viene
el debate
[Música]